if you're shopping for a Star Wars fan
who loves video games then the perfect
gift for them this holiday season is
Star Wars Battlefront trouble is if
they're that big a fan they've probably
already got the game for themselves
never fear GameSpot has teamed up with
Duracell to bring you the best gift
ideas for the brave little battlefront
errs in your life I'm not saying this
video is your only hope but it's your
only hope
playing battlefront may be a great way
to act out your Star Wars fantasies in
the digital realm but when it comes to
real life everybody needs a lightsaber
and the hottest lightsaber this season
is obviously kylo Ren's burning red
beauty with that sweet new cross guard
the glowing red light looks great in the
dark and the true - trailer sounds
crackle with the energy of this sinister
weapon as part of Hasbro's officially
licensed blade builders collection the
package also comes with a light dagger
and a connector for linking it up to
other lightsabers you may already own be
sure that the lucky recipient can and to
their heart's content by including two
double-a Duracell quantum batteries in
the package or else the dark side may
have already won though there's a fair
amount of conflict in the Star Wars
universe there are still plenty of
peaceable characters for you to admire
and cuddle yes I said cuddle and no I
don't mean he walks or wookies the
frontrunner for the most adorable
addition to cannon is bb-8 a roly poly
droid that can roll into your life in
one of two appealing ways the first is
this droid by Sphero closest we can get
to a droid at least without dealing with
some shady Jawas you can control it with
an app on your smartphone or just let it
roll around and intermittently beep at
you or if this guy's a little too solid
for you you can go full-on squishy with
this adorable little plushie from the
Disney Store who's a cute little toy who
is it it's you yes it is in addition to
playing a game or watching a movie that
star wars fan in your life is gonna love
preparing for the release of the force
awakens with that most high-tech and
futuristic of pursuits reading a book
yes a book can go toe-to-toe with the
best Star Wars has to offer especially
when that book is Star Wars
a pop-up guide to the galaxy artist and
author Matthew Reinhart created this
exquisite tome that's packed with lore
and engineered to
stop the page seriously you might want
to watch how close you sit to this thing
when you read it safety first
that safety warning goes double for our
final suggestion the perfect gift for
the budding bounty hunter in your life
the Millennium Falcon quadrotor drone
which is not here right now who smuggle
the Millennium Falcon oh here we go
get over here it's got four rotors it's
got lights
it's got sounds and remote control for
you to pilot your very own version of
the Kessel run it can take a bit to get
the hang of flying it but once you do
you'll soon be feeling you're a very own
version of that Han Solo swagger with
these gifts in mind you'll make the Star
Wars fans in your life very happy indeed
there's a lot of Star Wars excitement in
the air this holiday season have fun
making your gift-giving a part of it
you